it was a story that captured the world's
attention trapped underground for 69
days the ordeal is finally over
the loss of the 33 Chilean miners is
winched to the surface as a billion
people watch the news coverage on TV
Yoga for EMF ABC vamos selenium Oliveira
at what peaking agreement the
nail-biting rescue of the 33 captivated
the world and Chilean celebrated it as a
national achievement but it was perhaps
the last moment of joy for all those in
Chile's copper industry just months
after the miraculous rescue the copper
market came plunging back down to earth
mining companies cut costs as the copper
price lost its luster the high salaries
that enriched a generation of miners are
no longer affordable for an industry
that has to dig deeper to reach the
earth proper deposit work is doing one
of the most dangerous jobs are fighting
to retain the high salaries they once
commanded this year they held the
longest mining strike in nearly 50 years
will make the movie company deliver with
the things it does it will sort of sound
with photos that agha copper runs
through the veins of Chile cities have
risen out of the desert fuelled by
exports of the metal as copper generated
as much as a fifth of GDP - became some
of the best paid workers in the country
is walking around eleven of them Agartha
probably regular these people but again
knows no didn't necessarily mean idea
Chile's copper boom has fizzled out but
copper fuels everything in the wiring in
our cities the batteries in our phones
as a country struggle to adjust to new
reality can the good times ever return
for Chile's copper industry
[Music]
Chile is a country built on copper
[Music]
during the boom years the price of
copper more than quadrupled mainly
driven by insatiable demand from China
copper Kari Chile's economy to an
average of 4 percent growth per year
fueling the rise of mining cities such
as Antofagasta and Kalama in the first
decade of this century Chile's copper
boom made the country one of the richest
in Latin America - Road coppers wave
sharing in the wealth from the boom
Ronaldo was born and raised in Kalama
city of about a hundred and forty
thousand people in northern Chile he
works at the smelter the chuquicamata
copper mine but 33 years before retiring
this year y cuando en si la empresa
cannot de miedo
porque Alain de sheriff initial el reloj
I entered in Makena - or me that is in
cuenta a can take a divot osechi say
after grande Christmas in Toronto Plata
he commanded Angelo justo Darrell
electability economic available familia
de sousa era
beyond on no novice perfec lo siento y
tener el condor give Tredegar say grande
me no porque vas a tener una cosa
complain mikasa completely evil that it
was healing see ho - in Chile received
bonuses as high as thirty five thousand
US dollars just for signing on to new
contracts every few years
Reynaldo it took early retirement when
the state-owned miner Koudelka was
cutting costs at chuquicamata his career
has enabled him to buy four houses and
two cars he represents the generation of
miners who benefited most from coppers
boom
Pramila bean idea y es su cinta de la
ciudad de Kalama VC ho Pataca knows no
zeros la cetera Sahar laminaria
el mayor del que más - circa yada
Saharan chooki
andand a lot Ottoman era
no tool acceptance a decoder una
purchased wand Oh Thomas when des at our
studio Laura Kay Tyagi a professional
nope when tricked on poco porque no
necesitan engineers so say yeah Emil I'm
in idea
Filippo Kamiya no me papa mis hijos Roma
Mallahan Ana Ronaldo has followed in the
footsteps of hundreds of thousands of
Chilean men who have flocked to the
Atacama Desert to make their fortunes
the driest desert in the world with some
places that have never recorded rain it
spans 41,000 square miles roughly the
size of Cuba this moonscape is key to
our future on earth beneath the sand of
the Atacama Desert lies 30 percent of
the world's known supplies of copper and
half of the world's lithium in the 2000s
demand for copper soared as emerging
economies and especially China grew
exponentially what happened is that 10
to 15 years ago there was a major
increase in the speed of urbanization
and real estate investment in many
emerging economies but basically in
China and well buildings are and the
cities are very intensive in copper
because of the electrical grid and that
increased the demand for copper very
substantially and it really transformed
the country companies were willing to
pay large bonuses and ever higher
salaries and the copper price justified
producing an additional ton of copper at
almost any cost the boom years people
what happens in companies is that they
see this these prices very high prices
they feel that they're not going to be
there forever forever and they and they
privilege speed basically so you have a
labor of negotiation let's get it over
with
let's just pay and get it over with you
want to expand your production just hire
the first guy to come let's get it done
and that sort of approach makes sort of
short terms sense in a way
because you get it done you get
production and you sell but it's a
problem for the future right something
for the present but it has enormous cost
in the future
[Music]
company's hunger to produce more and
more copper also meant the rising wealth
was coupled with poor safety standards
and on August the 5th 2010 one of the
country's worst ever mining accidents
brought chili to a whole me nombre es
omar de la Roca Manero nombre educate a
fresca da de la vie na sans la greca yo
soy la serie criolla mil mi padre de
dinero de janeiro my Madre de la
Campesina por lo tanto de pequeno me
relaciones tema de la manera de un
principio no querías l Monaro relatio de
ver como mi padre meteos oof rien La
Mina echo and oh no lo y en la sangre
algo Omar work to the now-infamous San
Jose copper and gold mine where he spent
12 years a loader operator before it
collapsed in August 2010 Fatah ha con
muchos de run de Seremban sector
yesenia's a condom a hose k logica era
mineralogy
hey hey hey girlie Jana preservation
vessel velaro e pasa said kemal one on
Melvin puddin on some say warning signs
of a potential collapsed were ignored
when the mind to come 33 miners were
trapped 618 meters below ground for over
two months
Omar recalls the moment the mine
collapse en el momento de rumba yo means
Ostrava
cargando on kayvyun cuando CIN teal me
per se como de donde consiga es donde la
calle Roda Brujo comunicación bin ESO SE
tu aura sensation DK say salia lo ho ho
que se rent and oh ho ido yo been sigasi
Oh NAT oh no yo cubrir Loma grande que
se Oscar ACO toda Renzo Gracie oh no de
polvo no sabía nada
Adamo gracias por lo que llamo go Mel y
Peggy a most unnatural Familia sempai
cerana hacer Miriam en que a las voces
del D a la oración antes del Moses
hammer saldez llamo no satchel ago men
no lado Clara Daria dune case asean
primero carry t4 torah display Guevara
entire story como yet
pasar mucho de grado given of the
samarco Mercado temple or the rescue
became a source of national pride but as
the elation from their rescue was
wearing off they had to adjust a normal
life again nosotros tenemos diferentes
La Mina a a queston poco
in desecrate opal are icky a Tamiya
Tamiya chica and an over to memory okay
Kay Aquarius ooh acetate agait guarantee
no leo in 2011 less than a year after
the miraculous rescue of the 33 Chile's
copper industry hit another snag after a
decade of growth the seemingly
unassailable copper price began falling
it is now half the level of its peak in
2011 Chile's growth fell with it
copper's drop prompted big mining
companies in Chile including state-owned
koudelka bhp billiton and angular
American to cut costs in the last few
years
reduction in staff and attempts to cut
benefits culminated in a six-week strike
follow cylinders as a miner and
spokesman for the Union that led to
strike at the Escondido mine go India
pestle evolution de gato del mono Leora
in Addison Darien uno activist ahora que
a solamente una cosa boy llamo a nice
Vanetta company name of victim sa mo
Victo Bartle muchacha nella senator her
mo Victo Mori compañero de trabajo next
asana esto se los ojos amo el costo
easter-egg are no so dokodemo muchas
Impreza better than men tenemos que
tener una semilla
the union is aiming to protect all
existing benefits for workers and to
ensure that new employees receive equal
compensation law cellobiose Aldo D Phi
Delta Burke a real economy volution
Floridian tone signal spasibo da gamba
poor gente nueva con men on beneficios y
todos los trabajo de antigo que somos
nosotros estamos weston tone Sugino
Cancellara pero este trabajo
eval tonight Rodina soto edenia tose sa
unique a minute in total in una decisión
de gracias a la la hora de Bourgh debo a
to strike anything March when work is
agreed to return to the mind on that old
contract forgoing any timing on bonus
bhp billiton majority owner of the mine
these negotiations are expected to
restart within the next 18 months we see
this as an opportunity to restart the
the engagement with the workforce and
unlawfully try to reach a satisfactory
agreement if we compare Escondida
enough to two and a half years ago the
total the headcount of his Candida is
probably anywhere between 20 to 25
percent lower and that includes both
employees and contractors and we
continue to move actually more materials
so so yes our labor productivity has
gone up but yet it's not at the levels
that should be to be very honest there
is a natural turnover there will be
people with different benefits I guess I
guess still the new benefits are very
very good very highly competitive in any
other jurisdiction and excellent
compared to anything else that any other
worker in Chile would give mining
companies also have to contend with
diminishing copper deposits there is a
natural decline of every every copper
deposit so please get deeper holes get
longer and grades get lower and and what
that causes essentially is that the cost
structure suffers and and you need to do
things to have said that
the desert is not yielding copper as
easily mining companies have to go
deeper and extract more rock to find the
same amount of copper after a century of
mining copper the chuquicamata mined the
world's largest open pit copper mine
which once gave the Rockefeller family
their fortune
Cadell Co spending four billion dollars
to borrow to a depth of nine hundred
meters more than twice the height of the
Empire State Building that's in the hope
of prolonging the life of the mine to
2060 it's really hard to imagine that
this massive open pit copper mine is
coming to the end of its life there's
about 1,500 workers here who drive
trucks to the bottom of the mine but
only about 30% of them will be trained
for the new deep underground section and
the rest might lose their job - in the
u.s. also have to dig to similar depth
but work is they are more productive
than in Chile this is despite the fact
that they get paid roughly the same
salary while copper prices are -
salaries have risen productivity among
Chilean copper miners has declined
dramatically
the chilies copper industry is facing
shrinking copper deposits
higher costs and lagging productivity or
while China's demand has slowed and
copper prices have tailed off companies
are trying to adjust to this new reality
by cutting costs but they face a rising
tide of workers discontent if you look
at the underlying trends in
international demand for copper there
are some promising signs and I think one
of the most promising ones actually is
really the appearance of the electrical
economy electrical vehicles use much
more copper than the oil petrol vehicles
we use today also electrical vehicles
require a substantial electrical grid
which where where copper is very useful
copper is a vital ingredient for a post
oil future but Chile can no longer rely
on the perpetual growth of its copper
industry I think that the super boom
years were an exceptional thing and who
could expect something that happened
just once in history to happen again
right mining is going to be an important
thing in our economy - laser mining
country the copper markets recovery
isn't the only challenge for Chile the
problem is that in the next boom if it
happens we're going to have to find a
way to discipline ourselves but I have
to use some of it for the inequality and
poverty but another part we're going to
have to use it to finance an expansion
of new sectors
[Music]
Chili's proper inventory data crossroads
even if our consumption patterns mean
global demand for copper will increase
in the coming decades the Chilean
government and mining companies are
under increasing pressure how they
handle labor disputes will be a key part
of ensuring a sustainable future for
Chile's copper industry Nollywood
palpable are uneven along revolta get
offered amoxicillin procedure a girl is
a gentleman
dependable knows ok laminaria on es una
una Laborde dependi grow what's I
wouldn't LLM society but I can get
politically in getting cuando la semana
when infection is especially the
challenges for the copper industry will
not be easy to overcome but copper
mining has moved the country for the
last few hundred years and it's likely
to play a large part in keeping it
moving for the next hundred
[Music]